Democrats have a huge problem when it
comes to crime and anti-police defund
rhetoric and this next story is not come
to Hell a key Senate race down in
Florida is pitting congresswoman and
former police officer Val demings police
Jeep I should say Val demmings against
Republicans Senator Marco Rubio but
demmings might want to rethink this
tone-deaf joke
you know after 27 years as a law
enforcement officer there's no doubt
that's a tough job that's a hard job no
doubt about it but being an elected
office
that's a whole other level yo oh maybe
it was a lame attempt at humor not
likely to be funny to Cops across this
country who are besieged they find
themselves under attack more than 250
cops shot so far this year in the line
of duty morale in the toilet Department
severely understaffed many inner city
departments having problems finding new
cops but judge you can't really believe
that she hates cops she is the police
she says she's the police and she was
police chief you know a family of law
enforcement you know
the last I recall I I can't think of any
members of Congress who've been killed
in the line of duty and I don't believe
that this is something to make a joke
about you know I mean I think putting on
that badge in that uniform every day is
the toughest job you can have especially
saying goodbye to your wife your husband
whatever it is and so shame on her
that's not funny
um but I think also that the fact that
she votes with Nancy Poe Pelosi 100
percent of the time one hundred percent
of the time tells me that she's not into
the law enforcement issues that we would
hope she is based upon you know her CV
based upon the fact that she was a
police chief and in the end I think
she's as clueless as everyone else is
about defunding the police and wokeness
and all that nonsense and I just don't
think it's anything to joke about but
but you know Nationwide I don't know if
anybody realizes this apparently 45
percent of police Nationwide are
retiring uh 18 are resigning uh that's
huge that means that they've been so
demoralized not by them this one
congresswoman yeah yeah right yeah you
make a joke about law enforcement and
you vote with Nancy Pelosi 100 percent
of the time you're part of that game
I think she should be immune from
criticism she's done a lifetime of law
enforcement her husband Jerry Sheriff of
Orange County Florida I mean my goodness
the only job harder than being a police
officer is being judge jeanine's
assistant
that's not funny or your accountant or
your doctor Greg
I'll leave you out of the standoff thank
you but she has her main competitive
Advantage Geraldo is that she's a former
cop right and she goes out there and
insults cops that's really really stupid
politics that's going to be exploited
and then shove down remember Romney's 14
or what was it 47 47 right so I keep
hearing all about candidate quality on
the Republican side remember how we
couldn't stop hearing about all these
guys that were supposed to be easily
beatable Wing nuts you know
Masters and all these crazy guys that
were going to go up in flames and
they're all tighter ahead right now
Geraldo and all the wing nuts are on the
left look at the guy in Wisconsin he
loves Jeremiah Wright loves the funding
police Stacey Abrams is getting smoked
oh yeah Val just shot herself in the
foot
what's the woman in Katie Hobbs in
Arizona she's like Running Scared of
lake lake who they tried to boost
because they thought she was an election
deniers about to win the election
that's just really stupid you've jointly
changed the topic Dana do you really
believe Al demings is anti-cop I I do
not believe she is but I do say that
like if she's right that politics is not
beanbag and you look at anybody who
makes a gaff like that in the last two
weeks what happens the other side will
drive it home and that happens it
happened to Romney in particular that's
the one that first came to mind uh Obama
when he said you didn't build that well
okay well let's go like that was that
that was the line so she's been a very
interesting candidate one of the things
about her is that she was recruited
because she is had her law enforcement
background and the first female ever to
hold the job exactly and so so that was
interesting right but what does she need
to do as a candidate she has to raise
money from act blue which is their small
dollar donors and those donors are
basically the ones that agree with the
far left so remember Mrs Doubtfire where
you basically have somebody who's trying
to live two lives and you're desperately
making sure that nobody ever catches you
out because the the two sides can't
stand each other that they can't
intersect that's sort of what's
Happening Here but she got caught in
this and she's going to have to deal
with it
um interesting do you not like it is
this time
I'm trying to picture Robin Williams
it's more like if you have a terrible
sex life
there's permission to make an analogy I
thought it was a good comparison
but the other the other thing I want to
point out is the media has been trying
to say that defund the police never
actually happened that it's just
something that Fox News came up with
that the far right has come up with but
there are 20 cities that actually reduce
our police budgets in response to the
defend the police movement and it's had
real life impact and that's why you see
people say crime as at an all-time high
and they're connecting the dots to the
Democrats one thing I noted of Interest
Greg was how the majority of law
enforcement particularly sheriffs are
opposed to paldemics but that's because
law enforcement I've done a lot of work
with cops in Florida is so charged
politically they are politicians well
they are part of the political process
she's not again it goes back to the a
block she's not the problem the party is
as you pointed out this is we're dealing
with long-term consequences of a George
Floyd caused Ferguson effect and it's
hard to expect the Democrats to fix it
when they led the charge and that's the
problem she's a cop she's probably a
good cop she seems like a good person
but her party sucks and the Dems are so
scared of an anti-crime platform when
you point I think you pointed out that
the voting public loves anti-crime
platforms I think he said but so they're
scared of something else and that is the
activist they are captured by the
activists they they're allowing an
agenda that says that like any kind of
law enforcement enforcement is is
evidence of systemic racism any kind of
activity to to to to to Tamp down crime
is against a black person and that is
inherently racist because blacks what
the crime out of their neighborhoods too
I agree absolutely with that and maybe
this will be a sea shift maybe Democrats
will become more sensitive to their
constituents fear of being pushed onto
the subway and I also hope that Obama
stops eating dogs